welcome to screen junkies central this
episode is brought to you by mafia 3
family is who you die for from screen
jumping studios in the heart of Los
Angeles this is screen junkies movie
finds the screen junkies central we're
so happy to do this is a dream come true
I can't believe we have so many you here
live here in person and online watching
us on YouTube Facebook this is amazing I
want to take a quick moment to thank our
sponsor mafia 3 we wouldn't be here
without them this whole event has been
such a wonderfully and thanks to mafia 3
forgetting us to do this in honor of
that game that games about revenge it's
an action-packed game I hope you've all
played it we love this game it's just
this theme of revenge in there that we
really wanted to try and play out here
tonight on movie fights Kevin always is
so mad when he loses
last week we won it for him in honor of
mafia 3 to get revenge on us so for
today he's going to be the judge so I
thought here are two people that we that
we thought would be fun to fight him
bring him out Hal Rudnick Hal right Nick
you beat you beat Kevin am I the only
man to beat him aunt and my the only man
woman or child to beat Kevin Smith a new
kid and he seemed upset he was he he was
calling foul he thought there was like
screen junkies bias yes like that but
there wasn't but he does think there's
bias and he thinks it's towards another
man that man is the current movie fights
champion how about a round of placer Dan
Merle
I'll get his bells did you got your TSA
okay with that spoon with my backpack
it's fine he fly belts you can fight as
many votes as you want
gotcha I feel like Kevin just thought I
was a give you every point Kevin accuses
you of favoritism a lot he does well
it's only fair that he judged this and I
thought you know what it's with you a
third fighter to fight this kind of be
fun if I fought this so the three of us
are going to fight but the problem is
here's the truth
Kevin's a busy guy no fault of Kevin
Kevin's not here yet but we want to put
on a show
Kevin's coming and K we love Kevin but
come on respect to this this guy's had
brig all days working non-stop I love
this guy
but we're really crap what do we do we
got this audience there's someone else
I feel like who's out there and I hope
he's still out there there's someone
else who has a bone to pick with Kevin
and we thought you know what he'd be a
good guest judge until Kevin gets here
Bruce Willis no no no do we have to it
do we have him there we do okay guys
this is a surprise literally this just
happened I want you to give the biggest
round of applause to your life because
this guy just saved our hide to come
help make sure we put on a good show
ladies and gentlemen max landis
listen to that
oh my god Matt have a seat
yeah where we go do that hello everybody
I'm Finn rainbow Kevin Smith
I'm glad Kevin wasn't here because I
would have gotten nervous they might be
here I cancelled too late abuse to come
do this how about that cuz I [ __ ]
love movie crime movie is is the best
and I [ __ ] of the emmy-nominated
scream junkie oh yeah we love you good
sir
yes so I know you had a bone to pick
with Kevin like when you guys settle the
beef there's no beef but no no we never
had a beef but I thought we had a beef
and I was wrong well I said I said how
come Kevin's never acknowledged me a
bunch of people were like you guys are
treating together last year and I was
like oh yeah hahahaha very embarrassing
in this honor and thanks to mafia 3 this
honor revenge and this guest fight we
thought this is fitting and if Kevin
when Kevin gets here I might sit I might
make you to fight would you guys want to
see that oh yeah hold off the books here
guys because this is going to be an epic
once a one-of-a-kind exclusive here he
gets here he's getting time he's getting
here I am you're witnessing a very
stressed out guest judge right I'm
supposed to be to other places is
everybody having good comic-con whoa I
can't see even one of you you look like
a shapeless black mass just what I like
alright well I have to introduce one
more thing before he had this fight her
she's gonna be helping us fact check
this whole show you know her is the red
fury Alicia Alicia Malone come on by
over here over here boom Alicia's gonna
help us with the rounds setting up the
rounds yeah I've got my nice I got my
left to have some fun stuff to go yes
all right
guys should we do this now max this is
your show right now you can judge
however the hell you want it's my show
every time yeah you can use the audience
to help you make the call Alicia will
help you on the clock so we know how
long it the rounds take and we can keep
the show moving okay could the smartest
member of the audience please raise
their hand hahaha okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna need buy votes
weren't that many people that raised
their hands I'm gonna need a s on when I
raise a finger
how many times did Donald Trump provably
lie in his acceptance speech last night
no politics the corrected map number is
four there all right Alicia you have the
first round ready yes yes so our first
question
once again we're sponsored by mafia 3
and mafia 3 is an action-packed game led
by main character Lincoln clay so in
honor of that we have put three action
heroes in this bowl they have two blind
pick who is the best the three choices
Arnold Schwarzenegger Sylvester Stallone
or Bruce Willis who wants to have the
first the first pick go for it
and then you have to fight mafia three
Papa bless all praise - mafia three yeah
oh I'm gonna there's only one looking to
look all righty
Andy you're up first I'll be fighting
Bruce Willis guys oh let's say yeah jte
I got mr. Sylvester Stallone and I'm
fighting for your honor
ha ha ha get in the chopper if you want
to live
mm-hmm that's Arnold Schwarzenegger not
really all right Andy you're first max
you ready let's hear it now you're
judging the it's best Action Hero
best movie hero whatever you want to say
it's the hero there's only one effin
hero in all of movie action and that's
John McClane yippie Kay yay for John
McClane John McClane was it every man
who stopped Hans Gruber and his German
terrorists every action movie sense is
just trying to catch up even the old the
new diehards you can use those against
me all you want but that die hard is
untouchable you can't stop it Jack that
movie alone trumps I would argue any of
these movies action movies alone I would
say it die hard is the best action movie
I would argue all or around John McClane
is the best action you over around and
boo
diehard is unbeatable and now here's the
thing Willis isn't just the action hero
Willis is an amazing dramatic actor
between six cents with between looper
his filmography is much more varied and
I think his later years I'm sure some
people are gonna attack me on his fat
you're making a great point about your
actor he he's a very very actor who's
shown comedy he's proved in dramatic
roles and I think it's unbreakable is a
really good performance by Bruce Willis
when Bruce Willis cares he's fantastic
and he's a fantastic action hero and
that's where I stand all right Dan I
think this is best action here it's not
best actors and I just had the best
careers and had the best roles this is
best Action Hero
yes Bruce Wallace has a great action
movie and die hard but when you think
about action hero when somebody is
describing a generic action hero when
they're trying to point out to a badass
somebody's gonna kick a lot ass what do
they say oh we got Rambo over there
that's right we got Rambo and that was
played by Sylvester Stallone Sylvester
Stallone was action he invented the
modern action hero he's what Bruce
Willis was trying to be in die hard
Rambo is the greatest action here of all
time Plus none of this special someone
played Rambo in the 80s in the 90s he
was in yet another one of the best
action movies of all time cliffhangers
so not only did he rule the 80s he ruled
the 90s he went toe-to-toe with these
guys and he put together the little
singularity that brought all three of
ours together so sylvester stallone was
action he was Rambo he was the 80s he
was the 90s and he's the winner of this
round
here's the funniest thing I've heard all
comic-con cliffhanger ruled the 90s that
was I'm not a funny joke I rule the
night you know ordering order order um I
would know but I'll give you a movie
that was better in the 90s than that
True Lies from Arnold Schwarzenegger
mother-father let me tell you if you
brought scientists and thinkers together
in a laboratory and said we need to
build the perfect
Action Hero it would be Sylvester
nope it would be Arnold [ __ ]
Schwarzenegger he is huge larger than
life he's got the catchphrases let off
some steam
he's got the filmography you want
franchises Terminator 2 Wow
the original Terminator off-the-charts
predator oh my god him and Duke running
man running man is one of the most
underrated dystopian films of all time
Arnold Schwarzenegger hands down he's
got the filmography he's got the
catchphrases he's got the look all right
max what do you think well I mean I have
some questions yeah bring it so Andy you
just got wiped off the map because
you're right you're right while Bruce
Willis is the best actor of these three
men he is sadly not the best action hero
Armageddon last Boy Scout Armageddon
sucks oh he's great in that last Boy
Scout fifth element okay
fifth element is not an action die hard
with a vengeance is fantastic yeah but
your I guess list over here you can say
John McClane but then you have a guy who
was in the Expendables and Rambo and
rocky mine was in the Expendables yeah
except was very annoyed [ __ ] rocky
and a guy who's in Terminator True Lies
and predator Bruce Willis sadly is not
in the run but you're picking movies and
here's my problem I would argue
characters characters John McClane my
best character out of all of those I
disagree I think rocky is a more
interesting character that's not an
action movie
I decide yeah Rocky Ford's an action
movie he beat communism to death with
his fists
that's action we're talking about best
action hero I have a question between
you two yes Sylvester Stallone Academy
award-winning screenwriter yes Arnold
Schwarzenegger governor
that these men have done amazing things
considering how many people they've
killed on screen so this is a question
to you and I want you to think
analytically which of these guys loved
it more in their movies who was having a
better time wanted to be more
interesting because when you put
predator against Rambo that's a [ __ ]
slobberknocker that's a beautiful movie
fight and I think that you have great
movies that they go toe-to-toe but I'm
so dang I'm fighting Stallone I got to
do this oh [ __ ]
so that's just alone made a movie about
an arm-wrestling truck driver one of the
best movies of the 80s
I don't think Arnold Schwarzenegger
could have done that I'll tell you who
was having more fun it was Arnold
Schwarzenegger because several times
Sylvester Stallone's like all right now
gonna try to get that Oscar and he never
got the acting Oscar Schwarzenegger
kicked ass non-stop and then he was in
comedies that did well wait what's
happening fun are you saying Stallone
was bad for being ambitious for doing
Copland are you no I'm saying he was
trying Copland everybody round of
applause for Copland I'm so confident
ready round of applause for dark blue
not featuring not reaching its full of
but give a round of applause for dark
blue whoo I'm saying
Stallone made a lot of missteps Silke
Stallone tried to change his career
Stallone hung on to sound too long
Junior junior how she junior uh twins
and junior were successful comedies
Junior your singer what age the junior
is a success yeah she's now come on only
times Stallone tried to be in a comedy
was alright huh yeah a stopper my mom
will shoot when yes
utter garbage junior with him a Thompson
is a is a funny movie I was going to do
but junior is third behind the very
funny twins and Kindergarten Cop I gotta
I gotta stop action star and action is
Rambo when people talk about an action
hero its Rambo and then
necessarily answering his question who
is having the most fun no this is done
why honey drop it there's blood on the
mat I have to stop it Wharton ager
alright question was not what are the
best movies the question was not who is
the best actor the question was not who
has done the most or who do you admire
the most the question was who is the
best action star yes best action hero
Bruce Willis brilliant actor in
thrillers dramas and comedies as well as
action films Sylvester Stallone
sadly brilliant actor in dramas
thrillers as well as comedies and
Academy award-nominated you know like
serious pieces only one guy literally is
only done action with a few comedies in
which he usually beat someone up and the
win goes to Arnold Schwarzenegger to say
if you're watching live right now you
can tweet us use the hashtag movie
fights live people are loving the show
so far Patricia Carillo says moral Dan
just flipped the Hat [ __ ] just got real
and also delecia Russell says when's the
last time moral Dan put his hat
backwards hashtag SJ central the last
armwrestling tournament nice yeah of
course so we have heard that Kevin is
O'Donnell he's close hey max we need to
we need to milk around here do you have
a question you could just put spur the
moment challenges for a real line of
milk around yes yeah give me a little
wine I want you to give us a legitimate
fight here on spot really a really good
one on the spot all let's don't tell us
what we should be arguing okay only
movies for us yeah yeah most frustrating
film ending most frustrating film ending
I love it who wants to go first good one
and that's a good fight all right I'm
gonna argue this until Kevin gets here
all right how do you have one yeah not
yet not yet champ I will tell you the
end of Revenge of the Sith with darth
vader going no that killed any momentum
that movie had in it and it put it in
the in the trash bin for me so I'll go
with that
I'm gonna go batman vs superman donna
justice
you killed Superman at the end of the
movie as if you didn't do enough goddamn
[ __ ] in that movie already
you wasted one of the best books ever to
kill him when Batman could have easily
done that and then you gave us the dust
that he's going to come awake that was
the worst ending ever
okay that's ridicul Dark Knight Rises
here we go he's getting ready no one
went for the mist I love that that was
frustrating that's frustrating in a deep
way so I have a question for all three
of you and maybe this is taste but is it
just me or did they choose three bad
movies sure so of those three bad movies
which you sit through for I sat through
Revenge of the Sith like this i sat
through Batman Superman like this can I
argue why those two aren't right yeah
please so here's here's the problem with
yours who cares
it's over we got two sides not well oh
that's nice not to see Darth Vader I
agree that scene was dumb I was really
it was a prequel it was over no no no
this was the introduction to the
greatest villain in Star Wars history
firstly he does he goes no where is
Padme
and then he stomps around like a gurus
he goes they killed Darth Vader retro
actively Andy the dead rat I can we kill
that greater but what's more frustrating
the fact that now we have a DC you where
they don't know how to handle the
material and they wait Andy we've had an
amazing opportunity we've had that for
years and they did Superman move that
was one of the ideas frustrated I was
one of the only intelligible things they
did in that movie anyways don't expect
since Andy wasn't it pandering wasn't it
pretty clear by the time we got to the
piss jug that this movie wasn't going to
end one I'm with you but I'm you're
telling me the frustrating anything it's
frustrating that they tacked on such an
important moment and then my argument
Dark Knight Rises is cares that whole
movie was a mess why they're ending
specifically anyway Dark Knight Rises on
the record Dark Knight Rises is a mess
but Batman Superman pretty not a magic
Dark Knight Rises better than Batman
Superman you just said all go on it's a
better movie yeah just eat him uh Dark
Knight Rises is a better movie than
Batman V Superman but they talked about
the ending yeah the ending it was just
too cute Batman had such a cute Pat
ending Michael Caine was in Europe and
he sees Christian Bale having a drinking
in a cafe and it's just it was just too
cute from what we just this flog that we
went on it was too happy I don't want
that much happiness in my Batman movie
maybe I want a little more grit and
grime to my Batman I don't want him
gallivanting around Europe hanging up
his cowl you want that that naked dirty
Batman
I want naked dirty Batman rolling around
in the mud yelling about his parents yes
like uh you know a little bit of
contentment maybe but oh I'm off on my
euro trip Tata you know I just thought
it was a BS ending for one of the
grittiest trilogies of all time euro
trip Michelle Trachtenberg
Papa bless ya but see here's my final
thought sorry they don't rip noticed had
a thing to say which is one of these
endings has multiple frustrating things
in it well the other one only sort of
have one thing so which has the most
frustrating things because this one also
has the why don't you go buy your
Christian name Robert for the record you
said
that not him for the record you told
because I'm totally on him right now oh
yeah you know I last choice because it's
the best movie so the ending is the most
frustrating absolutely we got that
[ __ ] of Joseph gordon-levitt being
Robin may be taking over for Batman and
then oh I guess we'll never see that
come to fruition thanks for that little
dangling that in front of us it's like
when you realize you have five minutes
left on a test you go like oh [ __ ] and
you just write a bunch of stuff down cuz
it was like Darth Vader go know and then
it was like oh my god like here's the
baby he just runs away like everybody's
get to their positions it's like Luke
Leia I'm dead uh and it was like it's
the whole thing was supposed to be set
up in the original trilogy and it's like
the last five minutes of the movie it's
like you had three movies to do this and
you dipped around in pod racing in Jar
Jar Binks in' and hayden christian and
you did this in the last 10 min smooth
doesn't supposed to be the last three
movies sorry star wars gives me very
upset sometimes see I guess I'm going
with just frustrating in the sake of
like these two things were finales that
were disappointing to me what's
frustrating to me is there's a property
that's happening and they're wasting
it's material there are multiple things
that happen in that ending they were
setting up the Justice League they're
setting up the death there's so much
that they tacked on between that I'm
even including doomsday through that
that ending just tacked on so much crap
that wasted such an audible everyone
says for DC and Batman is to remain on
my favorite heroes hands down Oh the
Dark Knight is like one of the great red
and they had a barrage and it ended man
that I'm Superman was frustrating cuz
you're like what are you doing with this
but your buddy your kisses her man it's
not so much the ending it's a symptom of
what you you're guessing I'm guessing
you know what I'm calling it I've been
convinced yes I've been convinced Dark
Knight Rises is the best movie but every
time a new Star Wars prequel would come
out I would go this will be the good one
they're going to save it and that moment
I hate you you were the chosen one I was
like is something going to happen he
there is something is this about to be
good yep and then it was like nope and I
felt I felt Star Wars go away and it
never came back
so horse never came back it was like no
we gave up so you know what dan dan gets
the point
well it won't give them a speed round
yeah we have a lot of tweets coming out
Devon yeah Z says emulation alone is it
loud sitting up next to Dan and Andy yes
very very loud what it's loud here it's
very loud and a lot of people saying
that signs is the most frustrating
ending Haley why would you order why
would you invade a planet covered in
water exactly seventy percent made of
order come on and a lot of people max
want to know what would be your pick
could be the mist I mean the mist is
pretty rough um I actually just recently
saw a movie that made me think of this
called the ones below and I watch it on
a plane and it was kind of a captivating
thriller and then at the end there was
this super brutal twist and I was like I
couldn't believe it
and then the twist of the movie was no
actually we did the thing that you
thought was happening yeah like they
revealed the awesome brutal shocking
twist is actually not what's happening
instead the twist is it's what you
thought the whole time and I went like
this they give you an iPod on Air Canada
to watch it on I don't punch knocked it
over and it's looked at the ceiling and
then I open Batman Superman fast forward
to the Batman Superman fight watched it
and then the flight was over so it's
yeah that's I mean like probably the
most frustrating film ending of all time
is the mess let's give them let's give
him a quick yeah okay well getting word
that someone special is in the building
let's give a quick speed around or
anything York City someone extra special
but first I want to take this moment to
thank all about Plus members because of
them were able to do this amazing thing
which is so incredible thank you guys so
much if you would like to join and enjoy
20 weekly original shows amazing hours
of live content I don't know how these
guys do it join right now at screen
junkies calm slash plus
use the offer code esterday central 16
you'll get 50% off the annual membership
the best deal we can offer to you but
now no guys you won't want to miss
always Mad Max Thunderdome Oh everything
well we've got someone special look
who's here Kevin Stan Kevin so great you
to come wait Kevin max was very gracious
to help fill in here
thank max but I Max is a massive fan of
yours we've been doing this little
fighting we have a plan for you give me
your hand give me your head but I was
hoping yeah weak admit take a moment
here before max leaves and thank let's
thank max for coming in here yeah I was
hoping a lot of fans want to see you to
fight I don't want to fight max the max
is going to be on the pockets one of my
podcast we've been flirting on wearing
good ones for months yes and I want to
sit down talk to you about your Superman
and [ __ ] the movie scripts and stuff
so are we allowed to curse we've been
doing it so far um so definitely we'll
be doing that but if you want me to come
here fight him first let me get to know
him as a person to love them then we'll
fight so I'll bring him the podcast get
to know him know his weakness I'm not
then come to the movie fight Kevin well
how I was afraid of you I would I know
you're no I'll go why would I put one
silly one on you can say no I'm putting
on somebody no go ahead but max pressure
him in dota pressure max wanted to ask
best fictional movie band oh [ __ ]
good question Oh sois you see you well
square well where capito he's got one
I'm curious if you have one I mean I'm
tempted as the guy who's doing the
buckaroo banzai
series to say buckaroo banzai and the
Hong Kong Cavaliers
let me think though before I just blurt
that I don't want to be somebody tell
you here's why you yes you ready max
your [ __ ] Kevin's
no when I jerk off I'm [ __ ] hit what
is it what is your favorite baby of all
time great movie BAM I would say I would
say the best movie band of all time is
probably Josie in the [ __ ] couch [ __ ]
a well done
uh because there on the comp from the
cartoon or from the movie okay you like
the movie quite a bit I love the movie I
love that opening song all their songs
are we [ __ ] incredible
yeah six whole hours yet no all of
theirs you're the only other person's
ever sung that song with me out loud all
of you need to meet Seth Green all of
all of the songs yeah our actual really
good songs actually wasn't you now by
letters to Cleo yeah which is a good
band they're like a real good band
letters for Cleo did all those songs
yeah I did all their songs and by the
way they like regretted doing it
apparently afterwards because they were
like those are our big hits those should
have been our singles all right and that
movie is so subversive so much smarter
than it needs to be the way the band is
presented the way the music industry is
presented in that movie is a perfect
time capsule of that time and the best
thing about it for me is that it's a
it's it's like an iconic ideologue of
that era of adapting shed because they
made it better than it needed to be
yesterday didn't do the minimal effort
they made josie and the pussycats of all
[ __ ] things
yeah into a good movie how can I shut up
for him he's absolutely right
come on Kevin you get there's a better
one I will all right all right we'll go
weird then um best movie band Blues
Brothers
directed by yeah that's absolutely true
absolutely true I grew up watching and
loving that movie it's you're adorable
when you're like us Kevin Smith but like
that's how I was and am about your dad
your dad fueled my childhood I'd go see
movies made by her dad Blues Brothers me
and my friend Ernie O'Donnell I was fat
he was little we were like a bear cub
couple and [ __ ] like that
I could pull off Jake blues put on a
black I still wear Ray Bans to this day
because of that reason not totally so I
know end up watching that whole movie of
course is let's get the band back
together so we actually watched the band
get built I would argue that you never
really see that in many flicks and Josie
and the Pussycats it begins and we don't
even see their origin story like how the
[ __ ] to Tara Reid become their [ __ ]
you know guitar player whatever she is
so I would like to end not saying she
shouldn't have been but there's no
origin story at least with Blues
Brothers even though they had been
together they were split up and so we
get to see the reorganize em the best
[ __ ] music ever play it in a movie um
do you love that movie is that the
argument we're happy I do love that
movie but I do have a small qualms with
your argument fire what they did that
day also are good at getting away from
cops they have magic powers from space
uh what just because of the one car flip
yeah and when he floats up into the air
and turns blue that's true enough the
biggest problem with this argument is
that the Blues Brothers is not a
fictional band Oh excellent point
John John Belushi and Dan Aykroyd
perform live as the Blues Brothers true
so but since you're putting on a
character to be in that band like most
bands like perform as themselves but
since you're already putting on a
character to perform that that song or
any of those songs and then you take
those characters put them to film
doesn't that still count as fictional
Ben I don't think it does because it's a
fictional depiction of a real band fair
enough
josie and the pussycats is the fictional
depiction of a [ __ ] cartoon excellent
boy excellent point characters names are
Jake and Elwood not John why are you
here doing this get off the [ __ ]
stage shut up how well done how well the
Jersey represent but when they were
performed on Saturday Night Live they
were identified as John Belushi and Dan
Aykroyd The Blues Brothers that's right
you're right about that
but when did they become Jake and Elwood
the movie Oh redone the first time those
characters were named no I think they
were first no on the record cuz they go
on the record yeah come on now what they
also only perform covers that's true
that never oh my god Jose you mangy cat
are there are eight they are a real
cover band I'm gonna give it up man Andy
was less like waiting to see you meet
max like he [ __ ] knows you so busy
doing Pokemon go there yes
just gonna pick at you I'm pretty sure
ahead he was sending a dick pic while we
were conversations an act he's like I'm
so bored that was just a picture of me
but I have to say I am geeking out right
now just watching you to go back and
forth hey Fred you pulled out the band
argument that's actually pretty accurate
I have smart boy all right
any final closing thoughts we're gonna
have the audience I'll vote a vote on
that yeah they're not one of your
arguments you've been listening right
final thought max all right I was
sleeping you final thoughts that was the
voter fictional band from a movie all
right you voted for max Kevin that was
actually you know what it sounds like
max got all the Milani holes I got all
the old people it sounded you know what
it sounded like was let's go see it
let's go cena cena sucks if you are
using libel texting do we hand out cards
or not done this yeah oh you have the
cards left you the cards oh [ __ ] it's a
what it was a round yellow that was too
close
hold up the white side for Kevin and the
black side for Mac for this call is a
blank from Kevin I can't see well oh
yeah yeah the back what are you America
turn it up again
turn the lights up and it didn't know we
were gonna get political Matt and I
think it's black I think it's max max
max landis can we get him a round of
applause for max landis
Max is going to be at our movie fight
tonight San Diego Comic Con official
room 6de yes 915 if you're here please
come there watch it we have max Doug
Zack send some awesome special guests
you're going to watch another movie
fights their round of applause thank you
so much for coming max thanks keep
talking I'm excited at this donation
girl moment that was key count moment I
have to say people on Twitter are so
exciting they're so excited dizzle says
so great watching up to my knees
fighting that Kevin Smith and I saw
great when Jack Shipley said seeing them
debating movie bands is giving me a
nerdgasm that's the only way is that
what you would have voted yeah it was
the fictional band argument with some
widow put her over the top for me yeah
why didn't they say Jem and the
Holograms I was going to say spinal tap
Oh what about sing straight and they
sing she sings strangely yeah sing
straightly good by the way they're
brokering a major your oh man yeah we
hooking about shaking Chuckie central
does it
I love deadline I'm gonna call to our
sponsor mafia three thank you for making
this happen yeah yeah this is so
exciting game of revenge is bringing
together
lovers yes bringing together people an
amazing packed house tonight I'm sorry
people are here and also watching live
on YouTube and Facebook and on sj+ and
you can see all our schedule at screen
junkies calm slash central that's where
you'll get to see everything that we're
doing here it's incredible over the next
few days all right max we got it we got
we got to do this good you're going to
minute your guys are going to connect
again max thank you so much I know you
gotta get over back so I'm getting you
out of here cuz he left like two things
get America to a huge round of applause
for max landis get over birds Thank You
max hugging I gotta give you a hug
you're the best
now it's so much fun your accident like
you maximize again give it up for max
Max and I just made a playdate for
Vancouver he's working on a show on
Vancouver Dirk gently's and I'm gonna go
up to direct my second episode of the
flash in September so we're gonna get
together then that's great
we were making dates that was like
tinder in real life I need to play each
other yeah all right so cool right you
said you're gonna like that kid I did it
was right yeah what's up all right so
Kevin yes we're here cuz the Mafia three
art sponsored credo quia central and
they have a theme of revenge and I would
set that earlier that I wanted you to
get some revenge on us cuz I thought you
were a bit sour last time when you lost
to this man I did I went back and watch
the tape and I was like you're genuinely
shitty about losing a fake fight like
big you could see my face change color
like no no that's wrong Andy like I'm
literally arguing over [ __ ] that don't
matter so I was a little sort I know
you're a busy man and I'm grateful that
you made the time to come here so I
thought it'd be fun of you judged us but
I do it all the time anyway so I'd love
to do it right here max help with boys
like this [ __ ] screen junkies but yes
I come for the first round will carry
those points over but you didn't do the
next two and we have a speed round - I
have the Shogun's yoshu in all the
categories and I'll just be your way be
judging don't you chime in you can be
biased this is your show now so I'm head
dropping the mic Alicia's got the rounds
you go back to sending dick pics I know
I'm fine
oh you're in the fight right all right
so Kevin feel free to be as aggressive
as you like it's show so far the points
are one two how one two Dan zero
- Andy makes sense makes absolute sense
so let's keep going the question is who
is the best bad guy all right gentlemen
who's the best bad guy best bad guy give
you a moment to think about it I don't
need to think about this how do you have
one is this a belt mail no no how this
brings them everywhere right I just like
to carry him around exhibition purposes
only have you got one yes the best movie
bad guy or villain is Hannibal Lecter
from Silence of the Lambs
oh man should I said Vader for the
comic-con crowd okay
no it's Hannibal Lecter it's the best
actor okay um the for Hannibal Lecter
it's an Academy Award winning role for
Anthony Hopkins the movie is an Academy
Award winning movie he it's the one of
the only films where we are more
interested in seeing the antagonist than
the protagonist and some of the most
classic lines and the greatest acting I
ate his kidney with fava beans
I wrote down this is amazing uh you know
what you look like to me with your good
bag and your cheap shoes you look like a
rube like that speech given to Jodie
Foster uh Anthony Hopkins blows it out
of the water um and he's frightening
that guy haunts us it's such a layered
performance that's the best movie
villain of all time all right Dan movie
villain I'm thinking scary I think you
gotta have you gotta have a best movie
villain it's gotta be scary some quit
stallin I'm not I've built Andy jokes
about this he says he's talked for five
minutes before you say your answer but
you guys I think unrelenting unstoppable
unreasonable evil and for me the skit
the worst and the scariest movie villain
is the t1000 from Terminator 2 and let
me tell you why he is the best movie
villain is because it's like Kyle Reese
said in the first Terminator movie you
cannot reason with him
you cannot stop him he is more
unstoppable than even the first
Terminator and the first Terminator was
terrifying you can't blow him up it took
almost an act of God to defeat him and
he still might come back they still kept
I think he's playing to the judge on
that one come on my guy does both
basically both your arguments combine
them award-winning and evil those were
that's what I heard from each of you
who's both of those Heath Ledger and the
Joker this guy I mean this this role of
the Joker was already such an amazing
villain and he took it to a place that
no one even ever expected it to go that
everyone doubted and made a comic book
movie a legitimate like a ward contender
serious drama like it's all cuz of him
anybody who says The Dark Knight Rises a
Dark Knight is the best batman movie
they're kidding themselves it's because
of that performance that performance
that role
a terrifying anarchists who didn't give
a [ __ ] about anything and just wanted to
eff with Batman and that whole it's it's
just it's terrifying it's hilarious it's
scary it's the best bad guy hands down
Kevin what do you think about these uh
do I weigh in now yeah way more but just
kind of like I want you to try it let's
not Kevin talk yeah um cogent arguments
made by all uh Andy's are most
passionate his face went red while
telling that story
so right now Andy's got a bit of an edge
but you guys can still pull it off
thanks mate well I would say that the
t1000 that Terminator 2 was one of my
favorite action films of all time but um
a Hannibal Lecter is such a complex
villain he could brutally murder you cut
your face off wear it as his own and
[ __ ] escape or he can cook or he can
like he did to the prison guard I know
know we know we know is we were scared
for you oh yeah I'm gonna blow a gasket
um or he can cajole you trick you know
you into a false sense ability he can
milk you ya know he is he is brutal he
is a brutal cannibal and he's also a
psychological menace he will be in your
nightmares
he will be in your daymares he's a
serial killer he's locked up in a
dungeon with other monsters and
murderers he is what lurks in the
darkness and the light because he's a
brilliant eloquent doctor okay that
sounds like a gem now by the way here's
if it up what a performance best movie
villain again both of your guys are
gonna talk you to death they're both
gonna sit there and read hello Clarice
oh I want to talk to you about evil it's
just like shut up here's what my guy is
oh yeah we're getting impressions now -
yes my guy is a killer he's a stone-cold
killer and not only is he a killer he
could be your neighbor he could be your
mom he could be the floor that you're
walking on he could be the guy next door
the milkman you don't even know who he
is you don't know what he looks like I'm
running the other way when I see
Hannibal Lecter I'm not going into that
mental institution I'm not going
anywhere near the Joker I don't know why
anyone lives in God or not everybody
should have moved years ago this guy
could be anybody and you're not gonna
know who it's like no no Anna Morgan is
a doctor you're gonna show up for your
doctor's appointment and then you're
gonna end up lunch that's what you get
for no sucking Yelp how you got to go
people out there's one guy up here so
bad and in a good way that they you
can't even touch him look all I think my
t1000 is that scene in Wayne's world
where he goes have you seen this boy
ittsan that is sort of a funny guy it's
cool it's creepy oh come on Andy it's
creepy but it's not joke or creepy it's
not Lecter creepy it's cool effects it's
a guy just running yeah nothing
terrifying to me about Ron Patrick in
those ears you know I started that
terrific it's terrifying because of the
movie and James Cameron I don't think
that curse of the movie and James
Cameron what does that even mean it's
terrifying because it's terribly noisy a
federation of exactly enough fat hair
yes effect I'll tell you why love is
superior to the Joker rector has been in
a million bad movies Hannibal red dragon
oh and there hasn't been bad Batman
money tell me a bad Heath Ledger Joker
cuz the Hannibal Lecter has the
character and those movies are connected
aren't always funny really hot it was in
all of those and I'll tell you another
thing
Manhunter was the first movie to feature
these serial killer this story and that
was an indie film that was that did not
have a lot of Fame and box office but
then and a Silence of the Lambs came
along and spawned such what to three
sequels after that that's television
came a rarity of himself no but you
would inherit I'm talking about silence
I'm talking about one movie you're
talking about one would appear you guys
are all talking about the legacy of your
characters I saw Maya Sears any more
terrifying than mine don't have your why
bottles the most extreme unpredictable I
feel like the t1000 s predictable even
Hannibal Lecter let me night let me
finish my point
Oh Batman you'll always have Batman you
would not have the Silence of the Lambs
franchise and what continued from it
without the performance of Anthony
Hopkins as the most charismatic
frightening complex best villain Heath
Ledger in that sentence and the same
thing holds true no it's not true
because he's Ledger's Joker was in it
was out down between me and you oh yeah
no you do that all the time and II need
to cut that [ __ ] out that doesn't fly
things don't just happen cuz you say you
convinced the judge dead dan dan dan if
you do want to take a water break or
something right now that would be okay
he'll you got two guys talking about the
legacy of their films and the legacy and
the performance is it and the question
is who's the best movie villain and I'm
sitting here explaining why my guy is
the worst scariest toughest most hard to
defeats carries worst villain and I got
the performances and the actors the
thing in the leg is Lance's how do you
say that to me I did okay I could say
Kevin one time to level judgment you got
it you got it
somehow judge I'm ready to do this in
the first round of arguments
hands down Andy had me as a fought you
how your passion is almost won the game
but the logic of a Hannibal Lecter being
the the scariest worse what are you
calling it movie villain which one's
scarier the best bad guy the best bad
guy didn't hold up
when the Joker was thrown in to the mix
but your passion took it to the top man
you could have you argue anything for me
my wife could catch me cheating in front
of her and I'd be like hold on he'll
tell you about it and I think you could
[ __ ] convince her otherwise
but when we went into the second round
Dan [ __ ] really pulled it out by
pointing out one simple thing he could
be a floor
that there's nothing that dance balls in
your mouth Kevin that yes coz I too was
floored it was such a perfect response
you can't argue with that like at the
end of the day you can run from Hannibal
Lecter you can run from the Joker you
run into a room closer Tory look who
then the floor comes out so we got to
give it up to the t1000 you want that
like am i right yeah good arguments an
excellent argument you can't run from
the [ __ ] floor kids so that's Dan
with two points how with one Andy still
zero after you were close to man on the
first argument Andy's gonna get up on
the board the floor was I was hoping you
can hear that it was a good argue I
heard the floor you knew is over when he
brought it no way I always picked in
yeah he's the champ for a reason a lot
of people on Twitter saying what about
Hans Gruber I would say that was best
performance but no I thought of one as
we were talking also I'm Javier Bardem
as Anton Chigurh
I'm swanda from inglorious basterds I
almost picked so great yeah and then
Trevor Jones was disappointed people
didn't pick what's in the box
Kevin Spacey for you Kevin a reference
to that maybe yeah I mean Kevin Spacey
cool villain but like he comes in so
late in the movie and although the whole
movie is predicated on his axe yeah
since he turns himself in even though it
is like just to give him a head to box
it he never feels that threatening to me
oddly enough calculated the only threat
that I saw and Spacey's character was
like I got to read all these [ __ ]
note books like that's there are a lot
of notebooks that seem threatened but
other than that he didn't seem that
scary but it's a great name for an SJ +
show yeah
it's really really good okay we're
moving on to the next round and this
round is rated M for Mature er just like
our sponsor mafia three so the question
is best use of profanity in a movie
guest judge for this [ __ ] yeah man yeah
sorry kids we're gonna curse it's gone
first night and eg have one yokai a
[ __ ] it's the best use of single
usable Gary R movies use of car we all
say in our lines first yeah say your
lines dint what's yours
I'm so happy I get to say this is from
my favorite movie smile you son of a
[ __ ] right nice
how get away from her you [ __ ]
alright Andy your aliens pretty good
balls uh yeah because [ __ ] just
sets up such an amazing tone he uses it
it's such a I mean that the dynamic
between John McClane Hans Gruber I think
is one of the best in especially in
action films ever the two of them going
toe-to-toe is just so good and when he's
on that walkie and you're doing that
scene together and then he thought he
just rattles that off because a
[ __ ] it's just it's just perfect
it's his perfect use of script of
catchphrase of using the f-word in a way
that just is effective and then spawns
its own ubk mr. Falcon and because they
this they don't even try not they can't
say [ __ ] on TV but you still figure out
a way to say it's sort of on TV because
you have to because it's just that good
it became a [ __ ] just one of those
feelings and things that you just have
to say that I think just exudes one of
the best action movies ever and just one
of the best action catchphrases ever Dan
uh yeah I almost I almost picked that
but I went with I think this line smiley
son of a [ __ ] is kind of the progenitor
of all of them because jaws is I just I
just thought coincidentally I saw this
in a theater last week on thirty
five-millimeter for the first time
beautiful 41 year old movie yeah and
still that line smile you son of a [ __ ]
and he shoots them and the shark
explodes people still laugh and clap and
cheer and stand up and that lion is such
a release for the audience because the
last 45 minutes that movie are such a
pressure cooker it just gets worse and
worse
and worse and you don't know if they're
gonna make it out you don't know if they
can't and when he says that and that
shark blows up that is like one of the
best moments in movie history and I'm
not a historian I there may be I think
that was the birth of the action movie
one-liner
I think that line was the birth of your
hippy Calle [ __ ] and your get
away from her you [ __ ]
I think that was the first modern action
movie one-liner I think people saw the
reaction to that and started doing it
more and it still gets a rise out of me
I love that line so much and it's a
great capper to that movie it ends up
moving such a high note
all right Hal get away from her you
[ __ ] comes at a moment where everything
hangs in the balance
Sigourney Weaver is trying to save newts
life the mother alien the Queen alien is
got about to make lunch out of this
little girl and then the door opens and
there she is in that goddamn futuristic
robot tractor thing and and we're like
no what the eff is about to happen and
then that line signals [ __ ] is on like
Donkey Kong Oh like it like just as far
as flipping the switch in a movie and
shifting gears and telling you you
better hold on to your [ __ ] hat
[ __ ]
um that line is so perfect and it's in
the most dramatic moment alright put all
the counter-arguments what do you
thought so far Kevin uh it's down to two
in my head I don't want to say who it's
down to cuz they could still turn it
around just like last round I'd already
picked two but suddenly everything got
turned around but I'll be honest with
you I've [ __ ] the easy win would have
been what the [ __ ] is the internet from
Jay and Silent Bob strike back I would
have been like you're the winner
instantly nobody played to the judge
what a shame uh but everyone's still in
the running so let's go to defenses - I
just I just got a problem with [ __ ]
it's just when we're talking avanná tea
oh come on
Hey ladies anyone here like this you
guys where'd I get it
you can say it on TV you can say it on
TV
profanity we're talking we're here we're
getting dirty we're here with the man
who's the best at writing dirty come on
yippee-kay-yay mother that what they'll
say about me when I'm dead he was good
at writing dirty I guess it's just the
f-word
it just is stronger and it's hard to use
that right and when you can use the
f-word right in an effective way that
can really make it matter I just think
it's I gotta argue semantics dang it
these are great lines you're giving me
like what that's like what it's called
movie flights and I got a flight like I
just you had any words you could pick
you could use any f-word you could have
gone anywhere and you both just picked I
think they're strong lines but we're
talking about curse word scenes in
movies I just think you got to go a
little extreme with it and I don't think
either of those has an effective tools
at and I still think the dynamic in mind
is most it just it's more quotable than
Boyer's but here's the thing that is one
of 15 great lines that Bruce Willis has
in that movie the one everyone let it
goes who get together hope you lives
that's funny that's another lies it's
such a well-written movie such a well
written character that's a great line
from die hard I don't think it's I bet
you have two people I love and know what
line your movie was from until you told
them what see you your art verse you
argue semantics then you arguing with
our words it sounds like you don't have
an argument for yours so you're just
gonna go with little ticky tack argument
no I don't think the would I just say
what movie was a lot of people lines the
best cuz it's the best use in the movie
it's the most effective it releases the
pressure valve of that movie it is one
of the best moments in movie history
they're both quotable but I think mine
is the best use of it because it's not
something that's in the rest of the
movie and you got Brody who's kind of
this tightly wound guy and he's like
kind of this mild-mannered guy and he's
so pissed off he hates the water he
didn't want to go out in this stupid
boat in this goddamn shark will not go
after he's my likes my son of a [ __ ]
and blows up the clothes of it half
that's so great but I would say there's
not as much tension right there we know
the movies about to end we know he's a
barren Hills a shark you don't know that
you do not know that oh you know you
know that he's about to execute the plan
and kill the shark no I know that oh you
know it's fun in aliens it's such a
tense moment there's still the aliens
not gonna lose it
and I did 1/3 a growl it is at the back
we really turned quite Macomb like well
I took care of her but but yours comes
me before the last button the last
moment mine comes before this climactic
battle is about to be unleashed and we
don't know what's going to happen is
Ripley going to die saving Newt as as
the alien going to uh going to put a
baby and Ripley like she does who knows
is that is you gotta let one of those
face suckers on Newt you don't know
what's gonna happen but you do know that
Ripley has emerged and she's telling the
most disgusting gruesome the xenomorph I
mean one of the most gruesome creatures
we've ever seen on film and what a
creative creation that is and the mother
alien amazing she's telling that hey how
come on I feel like we're in Ellen's I'm
like Ripley let up you're just grinding
metal now yeah well she's she tells one
of those gruesome creatures ever get
away from her you [ __ ] and it's just so
cool calling her calling that mother
alien yeah I have to say how there's
already been so many great screenshots
of you just bursting out of your skin
yeah he's going to kill you the gifts
after today magazines like he's gonna
pop a vein over there but what do you
think Kevin Oh time to weigh in time to
weigh in Jimmy hey the audience too
don't forget they have poll they have
voting cards if you want to help no fair
enough if I need them um the
the name of the categories what
specifically I want to make sure of the
language is the best use of profanity in
a movie okay so the arguments about
where it happens visa vie mine happens
before the fight mine happens after the
fight that's irrelevant it's just the
best use of profanity in a movie single
line three wonderful candidates I I hear
the argument that like [ __ ] is not a
curse word but it is to some to a lot of
people now not so much anymore announced
cloak wheel of day was a bit but back in
the day when they made [ __ ] jaws
nobody was like what's that [ __ ] like
they were always [ __ ] that's a dirty
word but he was allowed to get away with
it because as Dan pointed out big tense
moment I love that line I love get away
from her you [ __ ] but I feel like it
owes its life to smile you son of [ __ ]
I think Dan won this argument but
pointing out whether or not it's true or
not it may be the birth of the action
one liner in Jaws to say that we don't
get to yep acai a [ __ ] and you
know I love the word [ __ ] so it
was hard not to pick you Andy but you
are representing a Bruce Willis film so
[ __ ] that man I was altima Lee though it
was the argument that swayed me which is
true we don't get to that line we don't
get to that line unless Brody says smile
you son of a [ __ ] and then BAM we're
off to movie history so I think this
round goes to dan dan gets the phone get
remote so yes dan has three points how
has one Andy zero thank you for playing
honor to play but now you get to help
judge when it comes to the speed round
Kevin's in charge well let's do a speed
round yeah I have to say a lot of people
on Twitter speaking of [ __ ] is
saying like I've had it with these
[ __ ] snakes and this
[ __ ] place
oh [ __ ] yeah that's a great one yeah
that would that might have one that
might have won the round
yeah that's a line that was literally
written by the public and then wound up
in the movie that's out feels like I'm
juggernaut right now chuck it up [ __ ]
is another one yeah all right we're
gonna see these
around there's a couple of questions you
guys know how this works I'm getting
timing this one so I will say question
you guys have 15 seconds each to count
your argument and then 5 seconds
rebuttal the first question is best live
action talking animal movie saying so
you choices talk about the best the best
babe you dug deep for that one but well
done
that'll do Pig Dan live action you want
to say kangaroo jack but don't do it
gotta give up the point before I did
good boy the only one that the only one
that popped in my head was homeward
bound the incredible journey which I
loved when I was a kid there it is we
got two contenders we're ready and gut
babe is a beautiful film and great story
drink James Cromwell who plays the
farmer know nur babe gives a wonderful
performance and babe has so much heart
it really has moral a moral compass to
it and it's a film that teaches kids
damn adults tons up okay Dan
yeah babes great movie but homeward
bound was one that I loved when I was a
kid the animals are so compelling they
don't even have to move the mouths they
just put voices over pictures of the
animals and people still love those
animals you got to Don Ameche and Sally
Field Michael J Fox it's a great journey
it's the classic story of the journey
home who doesn't love that story it's
such a good story I like baby it's a
cute story this is a classic tale it's
one that generations love okay
great battle how I mean homeward bound
is like a repeat of Milo and Otis
there's it's a genre full of repetition
babe is such a unique we've never seen
that story how ten dare you sir
homeward bound is nothing like Milo and
Otis it is a much better movie they're
both good movies but this would cut
sting okay Kevin feeling it uh well I
got to tell you the Milo and Otis really
[ __ ] you over man I was on the verge
you know we're bound I was like it was
kind of like Milo and Otis positive we
got to give it up for babe man that pic
moved his mouth he'll gets the point so
we've got Dan at three palette to
anyone's game oh let's see to the second
question and the speed round okay this
is a good one these two movies are
playing on cable which do you watch more
rats or Dogma more s yo each other a
coke you jinxed each other to death all
I can hear is I [ __ ] hate my dog yeah
I think how said that okay quick that
all right dogma it's like 49 50 minutes
okay ready
house so it's uh I got all rats and guy
there's so much to love about mall rats
uh you have a Ben Affleck you have
Stanley and you have your youth and you
have mr. [ __ ] Kevin Smith oh my
god
that movie taught huh it's about
something we can all relate to
growing up finding yourself hanging and
hanging out do you say anything so
whatever you have all those things you
have in Mallrats you got Affleck you
have mr. Kevin Smith I raise you an Alan
Rickman I raise you a Matt Damon I raise
you all the amazing questions about
theology and a poop monster in the same
movie I raise you Alan drip and going
what you're going to do it me with that
fish
which is one of my favorite line
delivers in any movie ever I love the
thing okayhow rebuttal how can one
possibly speak ill of a Kevin Smith
movie in this rebuttal
but I will say Mallrats is the more
focused contain better film than dogma I
think that you get the fun of all rats
but you get the great questions in a
deeper level with Dogma and you have
Carlin and you have a great cash you got
all the cash you are ads and so much
more in Dogma the bottle of doctor how's
it go
it's tough said it this is like a
Sophie's Choice right here man
uh you know both arguments who are great
I believe with both your arguments Kevin
Smith wonderful filmmaker but uh there
can be only one and I honestly think
that the argument that not only do we
get more Rickman and Mallrats than we
ever got one hundred percent more
Rickman and Dogma we also got a pretty
decent Alan Rickman impression out of
that argument
yeah but I'm in the middle of making
Mallrats the series right now I gotta go
with Paul rats
hey Hal gets the point so now we are 3 4
3 3 4 3 so we have a dramatic time oh
[ __ ] dramatic tiebreaker
and when screen junkies collide this
little is this amazing what this is the
last one and this goes with our theme of
revenge so this is a bit of a tricky one
to do in the short amount of time but I
believe in you guys
pitch your Chewbacca's revenge story
oh that's tremendous who's going first
give him an extra 10 second yeah I'll
give you want me to pitch mine while
they're waiting yes good no yeah I don't
want to stay might have [ __ ] cool
idea what I'd rather hear that well give
him another question yeah no I didn't
have one I just make it up and [ __ ]
probably have some [ __ ] sex thing
yeah all right Dan's got it all right
all right how can I give you 30 seconds
ready set go okay so this is the story
it takes place before episode 4 it takes
place before a new hope there's a line
on Millennium Falcon when they're
playing chess against Chewie when he
says that's because that's because uh
they don't pull their arms out of your
socket when they lose
that came from to eat revenge story
because who messed up his planet
Kashyyyk
it was those the clones and the droids i
want to baka going nuts through a clone
georgia stripping droids apart and
that's what that's how Han Solo knows
that he rips droids arms out of their
sockets when he loses cuz he went nuts
on droids oh that's the best I can do
sorry
Chewbacca wants revenge cuz [ __ ] kylo
Ren killed his best friend Chewbacca is
gonna kill kylo Ren how sneaking in
how's he gonna sneak in everyone knows
Chewbacca no one knows shaved Chewbacca
Chewbacca [ __ ] shave his body who the
[ __ ] is that
I don't know oh you just ruined Star
Wars how I read I just killed kylo Ren
damn go for it I I mean Kyle Ryan make
unexpected ljust you find a zombie one
ugly [ __ ] dan that's a great fan
fiction story how but you just ruined
the new trilogy that millions of hours
have been put into meticulously planning
you're gonna shave Chewbacca fine pill
kylo Ren yeah no no no no Helen my uber
house guy learn oh all day son I don't
know I quite what your story was he
wants revenge for one thing for kylo Ren
killing on solo right yes so this is my
Chewbacca revenge fantasy and my
Chewbacca revenge fantasy independent
from the rest of the gang
Hey ding-ding-ding-ding-ding what a
fight Kevin what do you think wow it
comes down to this Kevin it's this one's
a sadly it's and it's good sad for one
person bad for good for another it's a
pretty easy call I think we all heard
the movie that we want to see
a shaved circumcised looking - baka so
hell-bent for revenge that he'll let you
see is chewy dick take it all his hair
off the red thing popping out man we got
to give it up down how would that work
Wow Kevin how was that thrilling dude
thrilling like honestly it's fun to
argue but it's fun to kind of sit
outside and you really have to like use
the wisdom of Solomon to figure out who
the [ __ ] is more right in the situation
cuz really it's just degrees of
righteousness there's no wrong here
right it's just like it's opinion so
like that's right but that's more right
you know and that you get to shift
people over the line there were a few
times where I was like oh it's clearly
him then I was like oh it's clearly hips
right it's [ __ ] taupe like in terms
of like a sport where you don't sweat
that much like I enjoy it yeah
competitive and stuff I think I'm out of
a job right this guy was awesome at that
yeah what did he we got a couple minutes
before we gotta make is there anything
you got going on we can talk about or
anything it wouldn't say why I was late
I was doing an interview and I don't
want to sound bragging [ __ ] but we were
doing an interview for the show we're
doing geeking out which starts airing on
Sunday night on AMC after preacher so we
talked to Seth and Evan and Dominic and
Garth about preacher for like 25 30
minutes and I got to blow two boys up
cuz I you know you get in this business
like I've known set for a while but like
I haven't seen him in a long time he
works consistently I watched the things
he makes consistently and [ __ ] like that
so we don't retinas airily see one
another all time so I haven't seen him
in a bit and I was able to blow him up
and be like dude most people get their
foot in the door of this business take
care of themselves you know right away
they're like I want to make my [ __ ] I'm
doing me and stuff and they don't want
to let out the secret of how they got
there because they don't want
competition most creators have their
heads firmly lodged up their own asses
where it's like oh it's my world my
invention those cats made their dreams
come true like right up to the point
where they're right and direct in the
movies they want to make and see and
stuff but then they helped other people
like preacher have a long road to get to
any screen whatsoever one
my Rachel Talalay was attached to direct
aversion and Garth Ennis was like can
you and Scott Mosier my producer Carter
can you guys get helping us get this
make and we put your names on I said if
that helps at all put our names all over
it it did not help at all man and then
people like Sam Mendes tried to Sam Enys
tried to make it as well and he couldn't
[ __ ] get it there but these two
[ __ ] Canadian kids who years ago
they're so sweet and years ago they read
the book and they like this would be so
awesome
I asked that today I was like what like
like does it feel like you closed the
circle and he goes I just did it because
I would have been so pissed if somebody
else did it and [ __ ] it up so like
they made sure that they brought it to
the screen instead of just like hey
we're gonna do yet another one of our
things they diversified their portfolio
helped Garth Ennis finally bring a
really [ __ ] excellent creation to a
different medium it was a preacher will
always exist on the printed Foreman and
it's wonderful and you can enjoy it that
way but for years those of us like I
bought that book off the rack when I was
a kid and stuff to be able to turn on
the TV and have that show pop up as a
comic book fan who for years is like man
I wish they'd do two [ __ ] preachers
something like a it's a it's the noble
work I was like you guys are doing the
noble work not only make it cool flicks
for yourselves but you're helping other
people make cool projects like that's
the thing anybody ever gets in help
other people get in don't get in and
close the [ __ ] door as a shitty way
to do it get in and start pulling
everybody up with you even people that
didn't necessarily believe in you in the
first place because you never know where
some cool ideas gonna come from I assure
you is not going to come from people
who've been in the party for a long time
like me I've been around for a long
[ __ ] time I can't say anything new
that people don't [ __ ] haven't heard
already I'm like hey I suck dick they're
like we heard that in mall rats like you
know I got no new chick jokes if you
bring in new voices and [ __ ] like that
suddenly there's a better chance we're
all going to watch something that we
enjoy it's a shame when it's always the
same people over and over making [ __ ] I
like that because that means I get a job
but diversity is what brings you new
things that you'd never seen before
those two Canadian kids brought us
preacher one of the most quintessential
American comic books written by a guy
from another country no less so you
never know where it's gonna [ __ ] come
from but one if you ever get in if you
get a little bit of degree of success
where you feel safe enough to be like oh
[ __ ] I could stop climbing and looking
backwards I've made it to some degree
first thing you got to do is reach down
[ __ ] pull somebody else up with you
and that's what they did so it's really
really sweet it's I would say thank you
for helping us here too you showed up
here all the time and doing so nice to
us thank you how crazy is this yeah
having Sullivan here and you've been so
kind of so thank you for pulling us up
you extra thank all of you please stick
around with a message but I want to
thank Kevin Smith I want to thank all of
you at home we have anything else we
need to end on
I want to thank mafia 3 for helping us
with this fight on today thank you guys
so much thank you Kevin thanks for
watching everybody at home audience your
stay but thank you at home for watching
the stream we'll see you next week bye
Chloe Bard's thanks again to mafia 3
we're sponsoring this episode to watch
our previous show click the box to the
left and to see everything from screen
junkie central click the box to the
right